شكرا للزميل عادل عيدان مستمرون معكم
مشاهدينا في تغطيتنا الحيه والمباشره
للتطورات المتسارعه في السودان بين طرفي
النزاع الجيش بقياده الجنرال عبد الفتاح
البرهان والدعم السريع بقياده الجنرال
محمد حمدانو اتهامات متبادله مشاهدينا بين
الطرفين بخرق الهدنه الخامسه على وقع
اشتباكات متقطعه داخل العاصمه وخارجها
طلعات جويه للجيش تتواصل في سماء الخرطوم
وسماع اصوات المضادات الارضيه للدعم
السريع وفي الوقت الذي تتسابق فيه دول
العالم لاجلاء الرعايه اعلنت انقره تعرض
طائره اجلاء تركيا لاطلاق نار بمطار وادي
سيدنا في الخرطوم ولا اصابات الجيش
السوداني اتهم الدعم السريع باستهداف
الطائره التركيه والاخير ينفي
[موسيقى]
رحب اعضاء الاليه الثلاثيه التي تضم
الاتحاد الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه
الدوليه والامم المتحده بالاضافه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات وبريطانيا
وامريكا رحبوا باعلان الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع تمديد وقف اطلاق النار
الحالي لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه ودعوا الى
تنفيذه بالكامل كما رحبت الاطراف باستعداد
طرفي النزاع في السودان للدخول في حوار من
اجل تحقيق وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
وضمان وصول مساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق
هذا وكان الجيش السوداني قد اعلن هدنه
جديده استجابه لمساع سعوديه امريكيه واعرب
الجيش السوداني عن امله في التزام من
وصفهم بالمتمردين في اشاره لقوات الدعم
السريع بمتطلبات سريان الهدنه واوضح الجيش
السوداني ان تمديد الهدنه تم استجابه
لمساعي سعوديه امريكيه لتهيئه الظروف
لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف الجنسيات
وبدورها اصدرت قياده الدعم السريع
السوداني بيانا تضمن شكرا وتقديرا للاليه
الثلاثيه واللجنه الرباعيه وشكرت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده على
جهودهم المستمره في اجلاء المواطنين
والمقيمين منذ اندلاع الازمه في السودان
واعلن بيان الدعم السريع التزامها بمقترح
ثلاثيه والرباعيه بتمديد الهدنه الانسانيه
لمده 72 ساعه بدءا من الثانيه عشره من
مساء الخميس السابع والعشرين من ابريل
الجهل
[تصفيق]
ومن جانبها رحبت القوه المدنيه الموقعه
على الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان
بالمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه لتمديد
الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه وشددت على ضروره
الالتزام بها من اجل وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار واضافت انها تتابع عن كتب خطوات
تنفيذ المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه
الراميه لوقف المواجهات في السودان وتشد
على ايدي قياده القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع التي تعاطت بايجابيه مع هذه
المبادره
[تصفيق]
من اقليم دارفور ينضم الينا الصحفي صالح
ابو علامه سيد صالح مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه على شاشه العربيه اريد ان ابدا
بالسؤال عن دارفور ذاتها الوضع فيها الى
اين يتجه حتى اللحظه اليوم الحديث عن 74
قتيلا في القتال الدائر بمنطقه الجنينه في
دارفور
نعم اليوم الوضع في مدينه غربيه كارفور
يتجه نحو التهدئه حتى الان توقفت اصوات
الرصاص في الاحياء التي دار فيها الابتسام
جراء الخمس ايام الماضيه هنالك
يعني تهدئه للامور على ارض الدربي الواقع
هنالك ايضا مبادرات لتضخم من حاكم
ليله البارحه عن ارسال سيارات تابعه
لحركات الكفاح المسلحه الحركات الموقعه
على اتفاق وهي فرط محايد في هذا الصراع
قال بان يمكن لهذه القوات ان تدخل بين
المتحاربين وتفصل بين المتحاربين وتساهم
في الجرحى وايضا تساهم في تحسين الوضع
الانساني المترجي جدا هذه الايام
[موسيقى]
هنالك ايضا اتجاه في دارفور لتدخل الشرطه
في بعض الاماكن مثلا في جنوب دارفور نشرت
قوات الشرطه عدد من الجنود بهدف التامين
الاسواق وتامين المنشات الحكوميه هذه
الخطوه جاءت في هذا الصباح واصدر المكتب
الصحفي المش روطه بجنوب دارفور تعميما قال
فيه بان القوات في الاسواق وخفف بعض
الارقام
للتبليغ عن عمليات النهب والسلب التي تطال
المحلات
الوقود هل هناك عمليات نهب وسرقه وجرائم
ايضا في دارفور
نعم يعني في هذا الصراع تدربت اكثر دارفور
من عمليات الذهب
والكلب والاحتراب الموجود بين القبائل
خاصه في غرب دارفور مدينه الجنينه حيث تم
نهب سوق الجنينه بالكامل ثم نهب مقرات
المنظمات الامميه والوطنيه بمدينه الجنينه
تم نهد الصيدليات نهب مخازن الدواء وايضا
تم تدمير كامل لمستشفى
واجهزه الاشعه وكل
الاجهزه التي تستخدم في مثل هذه الاحداث
بالمستشفى عمليات النهب والتمره حتى هذا
الصباح في مدينه
هنالك بعض محطات الوقود تعرضت
للنهب وايضا بعض التجار
[موسيقى]
بسوق بهدف اخذ
بضائعهم ولكن ايضا تعرضوا لنهب من قبل في
مدينه البنينه الوضع في دارفور يعني على
الشارع نرى عقده الدراجات الناريه التي
كانت مختفيه منذ ثمانيه اعوام هنالك عوده
ايضا السلاح على ارض الواقع كل هذا يشير
لتفاقم الاوضاع الامنيه في دارفور هذا
الامر يحتاج الى وقت جميع الجهات الرسميه
والشعبيه من اي عوده الامور الى نصابها
الطبيعي واذا لم تتدخل اطراف محايده ولم
يعني يقوم مجتمع دارفور بمبادرات ستعود
الامور الى وضع لا يفنى عقبه خاصه وان
الوضع في دارفور وضع هنالك يعني ناجحين
موجودين حول المدن حتى في غربور اليوم
يعني المعسكرات الايواء تم حرفها تماما
حصل تشريد النازحين
في
مراكز الايوبي الجنينه هذا التجريد بدوره
سيؤدي الى نزول كبير او الان فعليا هنالك
نزول كبير نحو ساد
قريبه من الجنينه وتربطها حدود طويله
ما هو مستوى النزوح من دارفور سيد صالح هل
هناك يعني تدفق كبير للنازحين وان كان من
تدفق الى اين
نعم في مدينه جنينه هنالك نزوح لعدد اربعه
احياءها هذه الاربعه احيانا نزحت في اتجاه
احياء الامنه التي لا يوجد فيها اطلاق
النار بعد
المواطنين نجحوا الى
بيت سلطان المساليد
بالجنرالادارات الاهليه كانوا في السابق
يحتمون
بامانه الحكومه ويحتمون ايضا
ببعض الوزارات ولكن عندما تم حرق مراكز
الايواء هذه ذهبوا الى الاحياء المجاوره
وذهبوا الى يعني بيوت القيادات الاهليه
للاحتواء بها والبعض ايضا في القرى
المجاوره
لدى الى دوله
طيب يعني هناك موجات نزوح حتى الى الدول
المجاوره لم تقتصر فقط على الولايات
القريبه من الغرب السوداني اريد ان اسال
كذلك يعني السودان كان قد يعني دخل في عدد
من الهدن التي وصفت بالهشه خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين منها الهدنه الجديده التي كان قد
بدا سريانها منذ منتصف ليله البارحه هل
هناك التزام بين الاطراف اطراف النزاع في
دارفور بهذه الهدن ام ان الوضع مختلف في
دارفور ولا تزال يعني فوهه البنادق هي
المتحكمه والمسيطره على الوضع هناك
هو في الحقيقه في دارفور يعني المدن
تاثرت بالصراع الداير بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ولكن المعارك بين الجيش والدعم
السريع يعني محدوده تستمر لثلاث ساعات
اربع ساعات يوم ويومين لكن في غرب الوضع
المتعلق بعمليات النهب والقتال بين
المجموعات السكانيه الموجوده في غرب لمده
خمس ايام متواصله يستمر موضوع السابعه
وحتى السابعه صباحا وحتى السابعه مساء
يعني كل هذه المعارك خلفت هذا الدمار
الكبير لكن هنالك
يعني مناوشات بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
الايام الماضيه في بعض الولايات ولكن هذه
غير مؤثره على المدينه دائما الجيش والدعم
السريع في في مقرات الجيش ويعني هدوم على
مقر الجيش
وهكذا وبعض المناوشات داخل الاحياء ولكن
سرعان ما تنتهي لكن الخلافات بين
المجموعات الفلسانيه وعمليات النهب والسلب
نسبه للوضع الهاشميه للاحسان الكبير في
السابق هذا هو من المشكله في دارفور ابقى
معي سيد صالح سعود اليك مره اخرى
لنتوسع في الحديث عن ما يجري حاليا في
دارفور غربه السودان اذا مشاهدينا تلقى
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه الفريق اول
ركن عبد الفتاح البرهان اتصالات هاتفيه من
الاليه الثلاثيه حيث تطرقت الى الوقوف الى
جانب السودان والتاكيد على ضروره عوده
الاوضاع الى طبيعتهم كما تلقى البرهان
ايضا اتصالا من الاليه الرباعيه وكذا
الجميع خلال اتصالهم بالوقوف على الى جانب
السودان في حل قضايا وعوده الاوضاع الى
طبيعتها
حصلت قناه العربيه على صور حصريه لعمليات
الاجلاء الجوي للرعايه الاجانب من السودان
والتي تجري تحت اشراف الجيش السوداني حيث
تظهر الصور اصطفاف طائرات عسكريه لاجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب وحتى السودانيين
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهرت صور تم التقاطها بطائره دون
طيار استمرار عمليات الاجلال المواطنين
والدبلوماسيين في الميناء البحري الرئيسي
شرق السودان
[موسيقى]
كما تابعت كاميرا العربيه لحظات الاولى
لوصول سفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بمدينه جده في
السعوديه
الان نشاهد بدا عمليات تجهيز السلم لبدء
انزال الرعايه
القادمين من ميناء بورت سودان وعددهم 52
شخص من من 12 جنسيه نتحدث على دبلوماسيين
وعائلات واطفال وحتى كذلك كبار سن لانه
شاهد القوات العسكريه متواجده لاستقبال
الرعايه هنا في هذا في رصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بعد رحله استمرت عشره ساعات
كنا على متن هذه السفينه نرافقها من قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده الى ميناء بورت
السودان واستمرت عمليات الاجلاء في ظرف
ساعه واحده فقط عبر زوارق سريعه قامت بنقل
الرعايه من ميناء بورسودان الى
ظهر هذه السفينه السفينه جلاله الملك
الجبيل التابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
ومن ثم انطلقت مباشره من المياه الاقليميه
السودانيه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده في رحله استغرقت كذلك عشره ساعات
فيما يتعلق بالتجهيزات الخاصه بالرعايه
هنا قامت القوات البحريه السعوديه بتجهيز
غرف نوم وثكانات لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك
توفير كافه المواد التموينيه والاعاشيه
وكذلك تم الكشف والتاكد من صحه وسلامه
كافه الرعايه من خلال وجود عياده طبيه هي
مجهزه للتعامل مع الحوادث والاصابات وكذلك
اجراء العمليات الخفيفه من خلال اطباء
عسكريين السعوديين متواجدون في هذه
العياده للتعامل مع اي حاله كذلك تم فتح
كافه المواقع المخصصه للاعاشه لهؤلاء
الرعايه حتى يستطيعوا التزود من الطعام
والمشروبات وما شابه ذلك طوال مده الرحله
كذلك التعامل بشكل انساني كبير جدا وواضح
خلال طوال هذه الرحله من خلال التعامل مع
الرعايه وعند اقترابنا من قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه ودخلنا المياه الاقليميه
السعوديه التقينا بعدد كبير من الرعايه
نتحدث على يعني شرحوا عبروا لنا عن
امتنانهم وتقديرهم الحكومه السعوديه
قامت باجلائهم من ميناء بورت سودان بعد ان
كانوا في الخرطوم وقاموا بالسفر برا الى
ميناء بورسودان في مده او في مسافه تصلي
850 كيلو متر يعني وثقوا هذه اللحظات عند
اقترابهم من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده وثقوا عبرها هواتفهم هذه اللقطات
واختلفت المشاعر بعد ان كان هنالك مشاعر
خوف وعدم استقرار اختلفت كليا بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان هنا على ارض على ارض
السعوديه وتحديدا فعلى رصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده
نتابع هذه الصور مشاهدينا من ولايه دارفور
حيث تنتشر المئات من قوات الشرطه
لمن عمليات النهب كانت قبل قليل مصادر
العربيه قد اكدت نهب سوق الجنينه غرب
دارفور ومستودعات ايضا كذلك للمنظمات
الانسانيه هذه صور كما نشاهد الان ثابته
من ولايه دارفور لانتشار المئات من قوات
الشرطه السودانيه والتي تنتشر لتامين هذه
الاسواق اسواق
يعني نياله ودارفور ايضا كذلك هذه العربات
اذا
وكذلك افراد من الشرطه
لتامين هذه الاسواق
خشيه نهبئه مره اخرى كما نهب سوق الجنينه
غربور وكذلك ايضا حتى المنظمات
الانسانيه كانت قبل قليل ايضا مصادر
العربيه قد اكدت بان هناك عمليه نزوح
وحركه كبيره من دارفور باتجاه تشاد ولا
زلنا نشاهد هذه الصور امامكم الان وهي صور
ثابته متداوله
طبعا
للجيش او عفوا للشرطه السودانيه وهي تنتشر
وتنشر عناصرها ايضا في الدارفور منعا
لنهب هذه الاسواق نعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا
وفي ذات السياق تابعنا معكم اللحظات
الاولى لوصول سفينه جلاله الملك مكه الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بمدينه جده في
السعوديه وعلى متنها 195 شخصا من ثماني
عشره جنسيه مختلفه
وصلت الان سفينه جلاله الملك مكه وهذا
تاكيدا على عمليات استمرار عمليات استمرار
الاجلاء الخاصه بالرعايه من ميناء بورت
سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه عبر
السفن البحريه الخاصه بالقوات السعوديه
البحريه نتحدث على متن سفينه جلاله الملك
مكه التي وصلت الان
1998 شخص من نتحدث من 18
جنسيه جميعهم من المواطنين الاجانب وصلوا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بعد رحله
استمرت قرابه العشره ساعات من بورتسودان
وتحديدا من ميناء بورت السودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه الان بدا
عمليات الانزال من خلال تركيب السلم الخاص
بالرصيف البحري الخاص بقاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه دقائق معدوده وسوف يقومون بعمليات
الانزال بدءا من النساء وكبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه وبعد ذلك بقيه الركاب
[موسيقى]
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا اشرف عبد العزيز
رئيس تحرير صحيفه
الجريده اهلا وسهلا بك معي قبل السؤال فقط
اريد التذكير مشاهدينا بهذه الاخبار
العاجله اسفل الشاشه نشرنا قبل قليل صور
لقوات امنيه في دارفور
لمنع طبعا تامين الاسواق ولمن عمليات
النهب كذلك ايضا السفير الروسي بالخرطوم
قال ان الاشتباكات قال ان الاشتباكات
المتفرقه مستمره والطيران يضرب من وقت
لاخر وقال بان الوضع الامني لا يزال
متوترا ونعمل على اختيار طرق اجلاء
مواطنين من الخرطوم مصادر العربيه كانت قد
اكدت بان هناك حالات نزوح كبيره من طبعا
دارفور غرباء السودان باتجاه تشاد وبان
هناك عمليات نهب لسوق الجنينه غابه دارفور
ومستودعات المنظمات الانسانيه عود مره
اخرى ارحب
اشرف عبد العزيز رئيس تحرير صحيفه الجريده
مرحبا بك معي دعنا نبدا في البدايه من ما
نقلته وكاله
وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
يبعث يعني مبعوثا الى مصر
للتحدث مع الخارجيه المصريه في
سبيل معالجه هذه الازمه او ايجاد ايضا
كذلك
طرق
لاحتوائها برايك الى اي مدى هذه الزياره
مهمه ما الذي يمكن ان يرشح عنها كذلك
يعني بالنسبه للبرهان هي زياره مهمه
واساسيه خاصه وان العلاقه بين مصر
والسودان ظلت فيها علاقه وانسانه
يعني في الاونه الاخيره بان مصر في موقف
الحياد اذا هذه الازمه وانها ظلت اغرب اذا
وجهه نظر المؤسسه العسكريه
ربما هذه المظام وترفع غيرتها مره اخرى
وتؤثر على الاوضاع خاصه بالرغم من ان
الخطه
الاساسي بشكل واضح ام انه محل الازمه لكن
ايضا هنالك واضح انه هنالك ميوت بغالب
النخب المصريه تجاه انها تؤيد الجيش
السوداني وتقف على مسافه من قوات الدعم
السريع هذا طبعا بالتاكيد له تاثير
فيما يتعلق بالازمه ويجعل اذا مصر لم
تتدخل لي الازمه بشكل نوع من الحياد
بالتاكيد هذا يوقدها كثير من
الكثير من الوجدان المشترك بين الشعبين
السوداني وبالتالي انت تعتقد بان هذه
الزياره ستؤجج الوضع اكثر يعني الا يمكن
ان تكون خارجيه المصريه قد تواصلت مثلا مع
قوات الدعم السريع لكي توفد ممثلا عنها
لهذه المباحثات
الاخيره بعد اطلاق بصراحه الاسره بترتيبات
مع صليب الاحمر
تم نقلهم الى القاهره بسلام ربما هذا يكون
قد جعلها العلاقه مختلفه مما كانت عليه من
قبل ولكن حاولت ايضا حاول الجيش
الصاق التهم او قال ان الدعم السريع هو
وراء مقتل مساعد
اجلسيون الاداريه بالسفاره المصيبه
الخرطوم وربما ايضا هذا تحفظت عليه وزاره
الخارجيه المثليه ولكن حتى الان هي لم
تشير بما هي ردود الفعل التي ستتخفزها
عموما المساله هي متعلقه بانه ما هو
المندوب الذي سيصله الدعم السريع هل هنالك
خطوات تثير في ذاتها من الخطوه الخطوه هذه
فقط من ارتداد من قبل السيد البرهان هذا
هو الذي سيح حقيقه ما يمكن ان يكون فيما
يتعلق بهذه
[موسيقى]
بهذه بهذا المبعوث المرسل من خلال القران
القاهره طيب على المستوى السياسي سيد اشرف
عبد العزيز على المستوى العسكري هناك هدنه
تم الاعلان عنها دخلت حيز التنفيذ منذ
منتصف ليله البارحه لكنها لم تصمت كثيرا
الحديث عن اشتباكات للجيش والدعم السريع
حول القصر الجمهوري في عدد ايضا من حتى
المناطق الاشتباك وصل الى غرب دارفور ايضا
حتى التي لم يعني تهنا بهذه الهدنه كيف
تقرا الوضع حتى الان فيما يخص الهدم
بالسودان
من زاويه انها مناوره فرصه للمناوره وال
لان الرغبه ما زالت في عقليه قاده الحرب
بانهم يمكن ان يحققوا بانتصارا لاحقا بعجل
ما تيسر هذا منذ اليوم الاول منذ اول هدنه
وحتى هذه الهدنه الخامسه
السيده البرهاني ارى انه يمكن ان يقضي
ويحسن قوات الدعم السريع خاصه انه يجب او
يقف على نوع من التاييد بالنسبه المطلق
للجيش من قبل الشعب السوداني وايضا السيد
مسيره انه يمكن ان يحقق لاحقا على البرهان
ويقبل سيطرته على القياده العامه بشكل
اكبر ويمكن نتيجه ذلك ان يكون تغييرا في
سفينه القياده الخاصه بالجسم وبالتالي ما
دام ان هنالك هذه الرغبويه وهذا الطموح
لدى فبالتالي طبيعي جدا ان يكون هنالك قتل
الهدنه بين الفطره والاخرى الطيران غالبا
يبدا طلعته الجويه مبكرا
وتحاول قوات الدعم السريعه الرد عليه كما
انها تحاول محاصره القياده العامه والقيام
بكثير من
الضربات توجيه الضربات على ازاله تستطيع
ان تحقق نصرها التي
تعتبره انه حاسما مهما الا انه يكمل لها
سيطره
السيد اشرف
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالسيد اشرف
عبد العزيز الذي انضم الينا من الخرطوم
الانقطاع الذي ياتي من المصدر بسبب ردات
ربما الاتصالات او انقطاعها ايضا كذلك في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم لما تشهد من
مواجهات ايضا كذلك ومن تصاعد
يعني للعمليات العسكريه ايضا كذلك ان كان
لازال موجودا معي او عودنا الاتصال بالسيد
اشرف عبد العزيز السيد اشرف هل تسمعني
طيب ممتاز عادت اذا هذه المكالمه الهاتفيه
اريد ان اسال بالنظر لواقع السيطره
الميدانيه والعسكريه اليوم يعني منذ
اسبوعين وحتى هذه اللحظه برايك من
المستفيد من هذه الهدن الانسانيه في
السودان وكذلك من يعطل تنفيذها من هو
الطرف المستفيد من تعطيلهم
من المفترض ان يكون المستفيد الاول وهو
الشعب السوداني لانه يعاني من هذا البؤس
في الاوضاع الانسانيه والان يعني تدب
الحياه بشكل فيه نوع من الهدوء الحذر لانه
هنالك اشتباكات بين الصين والاخرى تدور في
كل منطقه ولا تستطيع ان تحدد هل هذه
الاشتباكات ستقف عندها ستكون في مناطق
اخرى وهذا مجعل المواطنين دائما في حاله
الخوف يسيطر عليهم الخوف والهلع ولكن
هنالك من زحف كبير ايضا من الخرطوم
لان دي فلازم في دارفور في خاصه الولايات
غربي دارفور في منطقه الجبيله تداخلت فيها
كثير من المسائل المتعلقه بالجوانب
القبليه وتحولت الى حرب اهليه بالكرت في
تعطيني يعني هذا سؤال مهم اذا اذا سمحت لي
عليه سيد اشرف وبعد ذلك تعود لاستكمال هذه
النقطه المشاهد اليوم عندما يرى الازمه في
السودان يعتقد بان ذات المشهد يتكرر في
الخرطوم الى دارفور لكن انت تذكر بان هناك
اختلاف لهذه الازمه ما بين الخرطوم ودار
دارفور نريد ان نعرف ما الذي يجري في
دارفور تحديدا وكيف تختلف الازمه هناك عن
ما يحدث اليوم في الخرطوم
المنطقه المشتغله والملتهبه الان هي في
ولايه غرب دارفور ولايه غرب دارفور هذه
تسكنها مكونات اجتماعيه معروفه يعني قبيله
المساليد وكذلك ايضا العرب وما الى ذلك
القوات الدعم السريع والجيش في هذه
المنطقه ولكن الازمه الاكبر ان كانت هنالك
قبائل عربيه اخرى باسم الكذابه هي التي
تدخلت وكانت لديها صرافه سابق مع المساليد
وحاولت ان تنتقموا وتنتهي هذه الظروف هل
لها بذلك تستطيع النحل اكبر كميه بالنسبه
لها من سوق الجنينه وما الى ذلك وتصدى لها
المساليط وكانت هذه هي المجدره الحقيقيه
بان عجزت
التي انفرت مدى القوات السيد الوالي خميس
ابو بكر في هذه المنطقه وعدم مقدرته على
حمايه المدنيين هذه المعركه تخ
تلف المعرفه في غرب
دارفور تتقاتل في فاميليا لكن عندما تتدخل
الاهالي ويصبحون جزء من الصراع فهذا يعني
تجلي جديد فيما يتعلق نحن اليوم امام
صراعات قبليه بين الاثنيات العربيه
والقبائل الافريقيه في دارفور
نعم في منطقه تحديدا في منطقه الجنينه
وليس في كل المناطق الاسرى المناطق الاخرى
في ولايه مثلا جنوب دارفورد القتال بين
الجيش والدعم السريع الشمال دارفور القتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع وهكذا لكن فقط في
[موسيقى]
ولايه هل سيكون لها اي انعكاس على ما يحدث
اليوم في الخرطوم برايك سيد اشرف
اما يحدث الخرطوم لان المواجهات هنا هي
مواجهات مباشره بين الجنس وبين قوات الدعم
السريع طيب
نريد السؤال ايضا كذلك اذا سمحت سيد اشرف
عن ما يخص عمليات الاجلاء اليوم في
الخرطوم يعني في اكثر من مناسبه تم مهاجمه
بعثات دبلوماسيه
منهم طبعا من قتل منهم ايضا كذلك من جرح
من لم يستطع حتى الوصول الى بوتسودان حتى
هذه اللحظه خفيفه يعني ان
يصاب او يحدث له مكروه ما هو واقع الاجلاء
اليوم في السودان هل هناك ما يعيق هذه
العمليات او ما يخيف الدول الموجوده من ان
تجلي بعثات الدبلوماسيه من الخرطوم او حتى
من بورتسودان
يعني بالرغم من ان الكل يحاول ان يدعي
بالرغم من النقطوات الدعم السريعه انها
قائمه بتسهيل عمليات الاجلاء لكثير من
الرعايه الاجانب لبعض الدول في المقابل
للجيش يقول انه يبذل جهدا كبيرا فيما
يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء الا ان هنالك
ممارسات هي مخيفه وتسير الحلقه في وصف
الرعايه التي يتم اجلاؤهم خاصه وان هنالك
تبادل في الاتهامات بيان الدعم الشريحه
اشاره ان الجيش يحاول ان يورطه في بعض
الممارسات المتعلقه بالهجوم على بعض
الرعايه الاجانب في حتى يقول انه يرتكب
مثل هذه الجرائم مثلما هو يحتني بالمدنيين
ويتخذهم البشريه
الجيش هذه الممارسات فيها ممارسات تقوم
بها قوات الدعم السريع خاصه وان هنالك
الظواهر اخرى سادمه
فيما يتعلق
الدعم السريع تعمل على نهر بسبب المواطنين
من الفيديوهات التي نشرت في هذا الاطار
اذا
هي مزحه
ومحاولات الكل على على محاولات ان يشيع
الكره الاخر بانه يمارس مثل هذه الممارسات
هل هو يعني يكون يعني يتعرض لعقوبات من
قبل مجلس الامن الدولي طيب اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على المشاركه معي في هذه
الساعه اشرف عبد العزيز رئيس تحرير صحيفه
الجريده انضم الينا من العاصمه الخرطوم
قال وزير الخارجيه جنوب السودان في
تصريحات خاصه للعربيه ان بلاده مستمره في
جهودها لاقناع طرفي الصراع بوقف القتال
والتفاوض مضيفا ان جنوب السودان لم تحصل
على موافقه رسميه من البرهان بشان مبادره
ايجاد وان حكومته تجد صعوبه في الوصول الى
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو هاتفيا
منذ سته ايام
يقبال من سيد البرهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي
الاتصال
[موسيقى]
يمكن القاعده
وتغير في المحال وتمشي لمحل معين
في وقت
ما كان سايل انه الناس يكونوا اتصلوا في
اي وقت
رسلنا الجواب المقترده رسلنا له رسلنا
لبرهان ورسلوه كمان
الرئيس الفقير النيابه عن الدول
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه ابي احمد عن
اجراء مباحثات هاتفيه مع قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو بشان ضروره
تسويه الخلافات بين الجانبين واكد ابي
احمد عبر حسابه على تويتر ان ناقش ايضا مع
البرهان ودجل ضروره تحقيق الاستقرار في
السودان وتسويه الخلافات بعد الاشتباكات
التي اندلعت بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا وقالت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بانها تقدر
الظروف التي يمر بها السودان وتبذل قصارى
جهدها لجهدها لدعم جهود وقف الصراع كما
اشارت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه ايضا الى تشكيل
لجنه وطنيه اثيوبيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين
من الصراع في السودان اضافت بانها تامل في
ان يتوصل اطراف الصراع في السودان لاتفاق
من دون تدخل اطراف خارجيه
قال وزير خارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكين
ان الولايات المتحده ترحب باعلان طرفي
الصراع في السودان تمديد الهدنه الى 72
ساعه جديده واضاف بلينكن ان بلاده تحث
الاطراف السودانيه على الالتزام بوقف
القتال وضمان وصول المساعدات دون عراقيل
تو نعمل بشكل نشط لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار
كانت لدينا هدنه لمده 72 ساعه ورغم انها
لم تكن فتره مثاليه لكنها قللت من اعمال
العنف وخلقت ظروفا افضل للسودانيين كما
ساعدت في تسهيل مرور المساعدات الانسانيه
ونريد التاكد ان كان ممكن ان تمديد الهدنه
فنحن منخرطون بشكل كبير
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه قال المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون
كيربي ان جهود بلاده مستمره لتمديد وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان مؤكدا العمل بصوره
حديثه مع طرفي الصراع لاجل ذلك
جهود مستمره من وزاره الخارجيه ويتراسها
السيد انتوني بلينكل لتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار في الايام المقبله ولقد راينا
تخفيضا في اعمال العنف التي طالت كافه
انحاء السودان لكن هناك بعض المناطق التي
لا تزال تشهد عنفا ومع ذلك تراجع العنف
ونعمل بصوره حديثه للتواصل مع الطرفين
لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار
نحن نرحب بمبادره ايجاد او اي مبادره اخرى
من اجل وقف القتال وادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه
شركاءنا السعوديون ساعدونا كثيرا في اجلاء
مواطنين واجلاء اعداد كبيره من الرعايا
الاجانب عبر ميناء بورتسودان ونحن ممتنون
بما تقدمه في هذا الخصوص
ونعود مره اخرى الى اقليم دارفور وينضم
الينا من هناك صحفي صالح ابو علامه صالح
مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى قبل قليل شاهدنا
صور لمركبات للشرطه السودانيه
منتشره في شوارع غرب ولايه دارفور لتامين
الاسواق كيف تجري هذه العمليات ونريد ان
نسال ايضا عن مستوى النهب والجريمه في هذه
المنطقه كيف يمكن وصفه
مدينه نيالا عاصمه في ولايه جنوب دارفور
بهدف تامين الاسواق وبهدف ايضا تامين
المؤسسات الحكوميه والمنظمات
بجنوب دارفور لكن هذه الخطوه جاءت بعد
عمليات السلب والنهب الكبيره التي يتعرض
لها سوغنيا وتعرضت لها المنظمات في نيالا
وايضا بعد عمليه تفلت كبيره جدا تعرضت لها
ولايه جنوب دارفور جاءت هذه الخطوه لتؤمن
ما تبقى ولا تبث روح الطمانينه في
المواطنين الايام الماضيه الشرطه لم تتحرك
لان الوضع كان صعب جدا وكان صعب عليها
التدخل لان كل تدخل ربما يحسب عليها بانها
استخدمت القوه امام المواطنين وهكذا او
امام قوه معينه ربما الجيش او الشرطه ولكن
اليوم بعد ان اتضح تماما بان من يقوم بهذه
العماله التخريبيه هم مواطنون يسعون
لتخريب الممتلكات ويدعون للنهب ويدعون
ايضا لتنويع المواطنين تدخلت الشرطه
واصدرت بيان وقالت بانها ستكون موجوده في
السوق معلوم ان فينيال الجيش ودعم السريع
تغاسماه المدينه الجيش في قاعدته بجنوب
نياله والدعم السريع بالشمال نياله
على الارض في مكانه ولا احد يعتدي على
الثاني هذا وفقا لاتفاق او وفق التهدئه
التي جرت بين المجموعتين طيب اذا من
المسؤول عن هذه العمليات عمليات النهب
يعني
الشرطه تتهم احد من اطراف النزاع في انه
هو من يقوم بهذه
العمليات الجرائم الناهب السرقه اقتحام
حتى المنازل ان كان هناك من اقتحام
للمنازل كما تم تداوله في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي صالح
للتهديد داخل المنازل وعمليه السحب وارسلب
ونه
معلوم في سابق كانت الخلافات وكانت
المشكلات تدور خارج المدن في قرى بعيده من
المدير لكن في الفتره الاخيره انتقل
الصراع في دارفور الى داخل المدن الكبيره
خارج المدن في السابق لذا نجد عدد من
المعسكرات حول المدن كان المواطنين في
دارفور يقصدون المدن لانها مناطق امنه
لانها مناطق يمكن ان يحتمي بها
الناس يمكن ان تحفظ حياتهم لكن في الفتره
الاخيره اصبحت حتى المدن غير امنه الهجوم
على المدن يتم من اناس قادمون من القرى
قادمون من الاماكن بعيده حول المدينه
يهدمون على الاسواق يهجمون على الممتلكات
العامه بهدف السلب والنهب وترويع
المواطنين لا احد يعلم يعني ما هي الجهه
التي تقوم بهذا الامر ولكن هم يعني
مواطنون ينتمون الى هذه الولايات يركبون
الدراجات ويركبون الدواب ولديهم عربات دفع
رباعي يقومون بمثل هذه الاعمال التخريبيه
في الاسوا جاءت هذه الخطوه للشرطه بهدف
تامين المواطنين بهدف التامين للممتلكات
في في شمال دارفور ايضا قوات الكفاح
المسلح دخلت يوم امس في هذه الازمه
بسيارات تابعه في حركات الكفاح المسلح
بهدف تامين سوق الفاز اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
اقليم دارفور انضم الينا الصحه في صالح
ابو على شكرا جزيلا لك
نذهب اذا مشاهدينا الى جده حيث يتابع زميل
سلطان السلمي في مطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي يتابع سفر 379 من الرعايه الصينيين
عبر رحله صينيه الى بلادهم الرعايه
الصينيين او الرعايه الصينيون قامت بعمليه
اجلائهم السلطات السعوديه من بورتسودان
الى جده السلطان مرحبا بك معي كيف تجري
هذه العمليه من خلفك الطائره الصينيه هل
من مواعيد
هذه الرحله حتى هذه اللحظه والحاله العامه
التي في المطار
اهلا بك نايف اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل بدا المسافرين الصينيين
وتحديدا الرعايه الصينيين الكان القادمين
من بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بعد عمليات اجلاء قامت بها
السلطات السعوديه الى مدينه جده هم اليوم
يستعدون لاستقلال هذه الطائره الضخمه التي
تسمى
سوف تقوم بنقل 300 وتسعه وسبعين شخص من
الرعايه الصينيين الذين وصلوا الى جده بعد
عمليات لجنه قامت بها السلطات السعوديه
بالتنسيق مع الحكومه الصينيه وصل حتى هذه
اللحظه الى المطار قرابه الميتين الشخص
وهم يصلون على دفعات متقطعه حتى يكتمل عدد
تم شحن الحقائب والعفشه الخاص بهؤلاء
الرعايه في انتظار فقط اكتمال وصول
الاعداد وانهاء اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم
من قبل المدير العامه للجوازات وكذلك
اداره الجمارك من ثم التوجه الى هذه
الطائره تربل
في رحله تستغرق 10 ساعات من مطار الملكه
عبد العزيز الدولي بجده الى مطار العاصمه
الصينيه بكين في ظرف عشره ساعات اثناء تم
استقبالها هؤلاء الرعايه الصينيين من قبل
ممثلين دبلوماسيين وكذلك عدد من المسؤولين
في السفاره الصينيه وكذلك موظفين واداريين
من اداره مطارات اجده للتسهيل مهمه هؤلاء
الرعايه من متوقع انه او سوف تقلع هذه
الطائره في تمام الساعه الثالثه والنصف
ظهرا بتوقيت السعوديه سوف تتجه الى
العاصمه الصينيه بكير بعد اكتمال وصول
كامل الى عاده نتحدث عن وجود
379 شخص من الرعايه الصينيين اكدوا لنا
مسؤولين في السفاره الصينيه انه هؤلاء
الاعداد او 379 شخص هم كافه الرعايه الذين
تم اجلائهم حتى هذه اللحظه من بورت سودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ومن ثم
مساكنهم بجده والمتوقع وصول اعداد اخرى
خلال اليومين القادمين قادمين من
بورتسودان بعد بعد عمليه الاجلاء التي سوف
تقوم بها القوات البحريه السعوديه بتنسيق
مع الخارجيه السعوديه
والسفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم نتحدث عن
اعداد كبيره
379 شخص سوف تقول لهم هذه الطائره
مباشره الى العاصمه الصينيه بكين في ظرف
عشر الساعات ايضا التحدث مع عمليات
الاجلاء لا تزال مستمره الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده والى كذلك الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده وكذلك عبر او
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي ايضا التحدث
المتوقع غدا وصول 1600 شخص عبر السفينه
مدنيه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه تحمل
على متنها قرابه الالف و600 شخص بمختلف
جنسياتهم كما اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه في بيان لها صادر خلال الساعات
السعوديه قامت باجلام
2991 من 80 جنسيه اجنبيه مختلفه لذلك
نتحدث انه عمليه الاجلاب لا تزال مستمره
من السودان وتحديدا من ميناء بورت سودان
الى مدينه جده ونتحدث هنا للرعايه الصينيه
سوف يكونون من اول الرعايه الذين سوف
يستقلون الطائرات بعد انتهاء اجراءات
السفر الخاصه بهم في مدينه جده وصولا الى
عاصمتهم الصينيه بكين ومتوقع ايضا سوف
تكون هنالك ايضا رحلات جويه اخرى من مطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده لرعايه
لجنسيات مختلفه خلال اليومين القادمين
ماذا عن الرحلات القادمه من البورتسودان
عبر البحر سلطان والتي يعني ستقدم الى
السعوديه هل من معلومات عنها هذا اليوم
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى استقبل الرصيف
البحري الخاص بقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده سفينتين تابع للقوات البحريه
السعوديه وهي سفينه جلاله الملك مكه
وسفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل نتحدث من
السفينه الجبيل على متنها 52 شخص من 14
جنسيه وفيما يتعلق بسفينه مكه كان على
متنها
395 شخص من 18 الجنسيه جميعهم وصلوا الى
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى تم استقباله من ممثلين
الدبلوماسيين وسفراء بلدانهم لانهاء كافه
الاجراءات وكذلك تم استقباله من قيادات من
القيادات الخاصه بقوات البحريه وتم انهاء
كافه الاجراءات الخاصه بهم ونقلهم عبر
حافلات الى مقرات السكن الخاصه به حتى يتم
انهاء الاجراءات المتعلقه بالسفر لبلدانهم
خلال اليومين الماضيه عبر مطار الملك
عبدولي هنا بجده
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
زميل سلطان السلامي مراسل العربيه من مطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده
دعا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني مواطنيه في
السودان الى الذهاب الى المطار في اسرع
وقت ممكن لضمان سلامتهم وقال في حسابه على
تويتر تم للتو تمديد وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان المملكه المتحده تدعو الى تنفيذها
الكامل من قبل الجنرالات واضاف احث جميع
الرعايه البريطانيين الراغبين في المغادره
على التوجه الى المطار في اسرع وقت ممكن
لضمان سلامتهم
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم
بيرن الوضع في السودان قد يتفاقم في اي
لحظه انه يتعين على الامريكيين المغادره
في غضون اليومين المقبلين واضافت ان تحسن
الوضع في السودان امر مستبعد
بشان الانتهاكات المتزايده لوقف اطلاق
النار في السودان ندعو الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع للالتزام الكامل
بالهدنه التي تم تمديدها وكما قال مستشار
الامن القومي جيكسوليفان ان الرئيس وجه
فريقه ببذل كل الجهود الممكنه لمساعده
الامريكيين هناك نعمل باستمرار على كل
الخيارات لمساعده الامريكيين على مغادره
السودان لان الوضع قد يتفاقم في اي لحظه
ونتواصل مع المواطنين الراغبين في
المغادره
اكدت وزاره الدفاع التركيه تعرض طائره
اجلاء تركيا لاطلاق نار بمطار وادي سيدنا
في الخرطوم وضيحه ان طائره الاجلاء غادرت
مطار وادي سيدنا بسلام دون وقوع اي اصابات
ياتي هذا في وقت تام فيه الجيش السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع باطلاق النار على طائره
اجراء تركيه في مطار وادي سيدنا ما ادى
الى تضرر الطائره واصابه احد افراد طاقمها
وفق روايه الجيش كما حضرت القوات المسلحه
السودانيه من وصفتهم بالمتمردين من عرقله
جهود الاجلاء بمثل هذه التصرفات من جهه
انفت قوات الدعم السريع استهداف طائره
الاجلاء التركيه مؤكده والتزام قواتها
بالهدره الانسانيه التي وافقت عليها
الى ذلك اعلنت مصر ان الجهود المبذوله
لتسيير عبور النازحين من الاراضي
السودانيه اسفرت عن النجاح في تسهيل عبور
اكثر من 16 الف شخص من غير المصريين الى
داخل الاراضي المصريه حتى اليوم اغلبهم من
السودانيين الذين بلغ عددهم 14 الف مواطن
فروا من المناطق التي تشهد مواجهات واعمال
عنف بالاضافه الى اكثر من الفي اجنبي من
خمسين دوله وست منظمات دوليه
من باريس ينضم الينا عضو الهيئه الكاديه
بحزب المسار الوطني عاصمه الجميل سيد عاصم
مرحبا بك معي السودان دخلت اليوم اسبوعها
الثاني من هذا النزاع المسلح بين طرفي
الازمه الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ما الذي
يمكن قراءته خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
ويمكن ان يكون عنوانا لهذه المرحله برايك
ارانا كثير جدا طبعا
متواتره جدا في السودان العسكريا
وتعلمنا الكثير صراحه
وهناك الكثير من المؤشرات من على ارض
الواقع منها
ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه
الجيش السوداني اثبت انه هو الضامن الوحيد
لمخدرات الشعب السوداني وللحمه الوطن
وانه في النهايه النزاعات السياسيه
والمصالح الشخصيه والتدخلات الاجنبيه لن
تحل مشكله السودان مشكله السودان لن تحل
الاطماع الشخصيه ولا بالعجله الخارجيه ولا
بالقوه ولم يستطيع احد ان يحكم السودان
عنوه وغصبا دون موافقه اهله وشعبه الذين
الان اثبتوا تماما توجههم الوطني اثبتوا
رغبتهم رغبتهم في الوحده
ورغبتهم في العيش والسلام ولكن
الاسد الشديد بعض الاشياء تدخل وتوصل
البلاد الى ما وصلنا اليه من هذه المرحله
المؤسسه جدا ماذا عن العمليه السياسيه
ايضا كذلك في السودان هل يعني اطلقت عليها
رصاصه الرحمه بعد هذا النزاع
المسلح بين طرفي هذه الازمه ام انه موضوع
مؤجل الان بسبب هذه الاحداث برايك
وطبعا موضوع مؤجل ولكن للاسف الشديد كنا
نتمنى ان لا يكون مؤجلا لانه في النهايه
حل ليس بالقوه الحال ليس بالبندقيه الحل
بالاتفاق وبالحوار
وبالجلوس الى طاوله النقاش والمفاوضات
ولكن طالما اننا ظلنا خيار البندقيه على
سياره الكلمه وخيار الراي فهذا يعني ان
البؤسيه في الحقيقه في السودان يجب ان
تراجع نفسك يجب ان تراجع نفسها مراجعه
حقيقيه لماذا اوصلت البلاد الى هذه
المرحله من التدهور في النهايه العسكر في
الجانبين سواء كان الجيش السوداني او سواء
كان قوات الدعم السريع متمثله في قائدنا
محمد حمدان
هؤلاء في النهايه هم ادوات الجيش او القوه
القوه هي ادب لا يجب ان نستخدمها في
الاستيلاء على السلطه ولا في فرض ولكن
للاسف الشديد بعض الاحزاب السياسيه
يعني للاسف لو كان هذا هذه الحرب بين
العسكريين لوحدهم كان سيكون الوضع اخر اخف
ولكن بعض المدنيين كانوا في الحقيقه سعداء
بالتهديد بالقوه وبالمحاوله على الاستحوال
على سلاح على ارض الواقع في جنائها عسكري
من تقصد من تقصد هنا سيد سيد عاصم ومن
المعني يعني بانه يعني يجنح الى طرف عن
اخر
المعني في الحقيقه
اصرت على تمريض الاتفاق الاطاري من غير
التعديل على التحفظات التي ابداها
الوطنيون وابداها العسكريون ايضا في
القوات المسلحه من ضمنها
الدعم السريع في سنتين او في عشر سنوات من
ضمن ما يتعلق بالعداله الاجتماعيه وغيرها
من القلوب التي كان عليها تحفظ كبير لان
الاتفاق الايطالي في حد نفسه كان ماعون
ضيق لم يكن مستوعبا لجميع القوى السياسيه
في السودان لان بعض القوى السياسيه التي
ليس لها حضور على ارض الواقع والتي تخشى
يعني السؤال السؤال بشكل اخر هل هناك قوه
سياسيه سعيده بما يحدث اليوم في السودان
وانها يعني تجنح الى طرف عسكري
ويعني تحجم عن الاخر
نعم هناك وفي الحقيقه هم لا يستطيعون طبعا
تاييد الحرب بصوره مباشره ولم يستطيعوا ان
يقفوا مثلا مع
محمد حمدان في هذه الحرب بصوره مباشره
لانهم يعلمون تماما ان هذا الامر
سيحرقهم سياسيا يعني لانه راوا كيف ان
الشعب السوداني الان في مرحله الصراع
العسكري متوقف ومتوحد يعني متوحد خلف
الجيش فبالتالي لن يستطيعوا القول باننا
ندعم التمرد او نريد
ان يقيم التمرد جيشا بدل الجيش السوداني
هذه هذا الامر سيكون صعب واضح على
فبالتالي الان هم يضربون على اوتار اخرى
تنتهيئه لانفسهم للمعركه السياسيه التي
سيظهر فيها مجرد الطلقات من باريس
انضم الينا الهيئه القياديه بحزب المسائل
الوطني عاصم الجميل شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
واخر الانباء الدوليه حيث افاد مسؤولون
اوكرانيون بان روسيا اطلقت اكثر من عشرين
صاروخ كروزا طائرتين بدون طيار على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف واجزاء اخرى من
اوكرانيا حيث اسفر الهجوم الروسي عن مقتل
خمسه اشخاص على الاقل وضرب مبنى سكنيين في
وسط اوكرانيا
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
فاصبحت جاهزه لشن هجوم مضاد على القوات
الروسيه وانها شارفت على نهايتها واضاف
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان هناك عوامل تهيئ
هذه الاستعدادات العسكريه للهجوم المضاد
من هو عوامل الطقس وحيثيه القرار من قبل
القاده للبدي والشروع بالعمليه العسكريه
المضاده
اعتبر مجلس اوروبا في قرار اعتمدته جمعيته
البرلمانيه ان نقل روسيا اطفالا اوكرانيين
بالقوه الى اراضيها يرقى الى مستوى اباده
جماعي المجلس دعا الى اعاده الاطفال بامان
الى اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان هذه العمليات
مخطط لها بوضوح وتنظم بشكل منهجي كسياسه
دوله بهدف القضاء على اي رابط معه هويتهم
الاوكراني
وزير الدفاع الروسي والولايات المتحده
وحلفائها باستفزاز بعض الدول في مقدمتها
روسيا والصين لجرها الى مواجهه عسكريه مع
دول مع دول معارضه واضاف شويغو ان الهدف
الحقيقي من هذه السياسه التي تتبعها
واشنطن هو الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا
وتشكيل تهديد للصين للحفاظ على مكانتها
الاحتكاريه في العالم
قالت وكاله عمليات التجاره البحريه
البريطانيه انها تلقت تقارير تفيد بتعرض
سفينه لهجوم الى جنوب من بلده نشطون
الساحليه اليمنيه وذكرت الوكاله في بيان
ان اعيره ناريه اطلقت على السفينه
البريطانيه كما اشارت ايضا الى وجود ثلاثه
قوارب على متن كل منها ثلاثه او اربعه
اشخاص
رحب اعضاء مجلس الامن بزياره الاخيره التي
اجراها الوفد السعودي والعماني الى صنعاء
واثناء على دعم السعوديه وسلطنه عمان
المستمر لجهود الوساطه التي تبذلها الامم
المتحده واعتبر المجلس ايضا ان مثل هذه
المحادثات تمثل خطوات قيمه نحو وقف شامل
لاطلاق محدثات سياسيه يمنيه يمنيه شامله
تحت رعايه مبعوث الامي الى اليمن وذلك
بناء على المرجعيات المتفق عليها وقرارات
مجلس الامن
بساعتنا الاخباريه من تغطيه الاحداث في
السودان انتهت نستكمل الساعه المقبله مع
الزميل ابراهيم بدر اليك ابراهيم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات